blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir claude
blanchemaison direct sur ft france avant
l'entrée en vigueur de cette loi qu'est
ce que cela change pour les hong kong et
oui elle ne change pas mal de choses
elle change évidemment les conditions
d'exercice des libertés publiques
puisque cette loi définit quatre crimes
au sens de la loi
le terrorisme le séparatisme
on voit bien de quoi il peut s'agir et
puis deux autres sujets qui sont un peu
plus vague à définir la subversion et la
collusion avec l'étranger cette loi
prévoit aussi de nouveaux organismes à
hong kong pour dans le fond interpréter
la loi et pour l'appliquer alors le
premier organisme est une commission que
préside à macquarie l'âme pourquoi pas
une commission de la sécurité à hong
kong mais avec un surveillant général
venus de pékin qui donnera la ligne la
ligne du parti
et puis le deuxième encore plus curieux
est un bureau de la sécurité qui sera
composé en réalité d'un jean d'agents
chinois alors bien sûr on peut on sait
bien que ça que à hong kong depuis
longtemps beaucoup de deux services
spéciaux chinois mais là ils ont pignon
sur rue et ils auront même le privilège
de pouvoir interroger en premier les
suspects au titre des quatre chefs de
cabine à sion que prévoit la loi
un pays un système
cette loi rom est elle en cause ce
principe écoutez c'est en tout cas ce
qu'elle dit ce matin le président le
bâtonnier des avocats de hong kong en
disant que c'était quand même curieux
que cette loi votée hier en urgence par
le bureau permanent de l'assemblée
nationale populaire à pékin et été
promulguée quelques heures plus tard par
monsieur jean ping le président chinois
et dans la nuit avant minuit par madame
car ilham à hong kong
c'est vraiment une procédure expresse et
sans qu'il y ait absolument aucune
discussion oleko c'est à dire
l'assemblée de hong kong ce qui aurait
normalement dû être le cas de plus le
barreau de hong kong se plaint se
plaignait ce matin de ne pas avoir eu
connaissance du texte précis de la loi
un texte assez long c'est une loi qui
comporte une soixantaine d'articles et
on ne connaît son texte
à hong kong que depuis aujourd'hui c'est
donc déjà quelque chose d'un peu d'un
peu particulier pour l'autonomie
judiciaire dont bénéficiait hong kong
depuis sa restitution à la chine en 1997
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui sur le plan
juridique on peut penser qu'il y a une
sérieuse entorse au principe de un pays
deux systèmes
ce n'est pas le cas sur le plan
économique puisque bien entendu on ne
change rien reste à savoir quelle sera
l'interprétation des acteurs économiques
alors les grandes banques comme hsbc ont
déjà dit qu'elle accepte et parfaitement
cette nouvelle loi
mais évidemment un certain nombre de
cadres d'entreprise de deux jeunes
également ne l'acceptent pas et par
conséquent la conteste mais ils sont
tout à fait conscients du risque qu'il
courait en l'affrontant ni gouvernement
puisque évidemment il serait arrêté et
mis en prison les peines sont très
lourdes jusqu'à la prison à vie avec des
possibilité de remise de peine notamment
pour des nations c'est à dire pour des
noms aussi dénonciation d'autres hong
kong et qui aurait violé la loi alors
sacré quand même un climat un petit peu
particulier
alors un club pourquoi la communauté
internationale sont elles si inquiète
je crois que c'est bonnière la
communauté internationale est inquiète
mais elle est divisée vous l'avez dit
que derrière tout à l'heure au conseil
des droits de l'homme de genève
d'abord les britanniques puisqu'après
tout c'est les britanniques qui ont
signé les accords avec les chinois les
britanniques qui ont exercé la
souveraineté sur hong kong
à la suite d'un bail de 99 ans
que leur avait consenti l'empereur de
chine au 19e siècle
donc les britanniques disent que en
effet cette loi est contraire aux
accords qu'il avait passé avec les
chinois un pays deux systèmes
et puis les britanniques ont déjà pris
une mesure qui consiste à dire que les
ressortissants de hong kong qui
voudraient émigré au royaume uni seront
en principe les bienvenus alors il ya
des restrictions
il s'agit surtout des gens qui étaient à
hong kong qui avaient déjà un emploi
hong kong avant la restitution à la
chine c'est à dire avant 97 et qu'ils
avaient un passeport intermédiaire entre
le passeport britannique et le passeport
et le les documents d'identité locale
mais par ailleurs l'union européenne
hier l'union européenne évidemment s'est
exprimé de façon assez modérée en disant
qu' il y aurait des conséquences c'est
ce qu'a dit madame ursula von der leyen
et en demandant à pékin de revoir sa
copie ce qui évidemment est sans espoir
et puis les américains ont commencé
également à alors là à mon très
sérieusement les dents merci à tous
blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales d'avoir été avec nous